the w-h-o failed in its basic duty to
save lives those are the words of
President Trump as he announced a freeze
on funding for the UN agency today I'm
instructing my administration to halt
funding of the World Health Organization
while a review is conducted as the
organization's leading sponsor the
United States has a duty to insist on
full accountability Trump has repeatedly
criticized the w-h-o throughout the
pandemic this time claiming it's bias
towards China is responsible for the
virus's rapid spread to other parts of
the world had the w-h-o done its job to
get medical experts into China to
objectively assess the situation on the
ground and to call out China's lack of
transparency the outbreak could have
been contained at its source
with very little death Trump says the
roughly 400 million dollars in annual
donations will now be reappropriation
though he refused to sever America's
relationship with the w-h-o entirely we
will continue to engage with the w-h-o
to see if it can make meaningful reforms
for the time being we will redirect
mobile health and directly work with
others the u.s. is the worst affected
country in the world with more recorded
cases and deaths than anywhere else
Trump's handling of the pandemic has
also been widely criticized and his
opponents say this latest announcement
is nothing more than a deflection tactic
well let's go now to our correspondent
Stefan Zeman's in Washington DC
Stefan president Trump has halted
funding for the World Health
Organisation's what reason did he give
for this decision and does he have the
authority to actually do that answer
number one he gave a very blatant
explanation for this he basically says
let me quote that he will halt funding
while a review is conducted by his
administration quote to assess the WHS
role in
mismanaging and covering up covering up
the spread of the corona virus that's
the reason he gave now can he do that
can he hold the funding and we're
talking about 400 to 500 million dollars
every year yes he can but as you can see
in the wording here he leaves himself a
back door he says he will review the
matter and we thought actually here in
Washington DC that this is going to
happen because he had alert to this last
week already so here you have it review
will be conducted by an administration
and the outcome may be may be that the
u.s. is now as a major funder for the
whu-oh not paying any more for or
contributing to the wh OS mission well
for now what will this lack of funding a
mean for the w-h-o which has been
spearheading the global response to the
corona virus that's a very good question
and I think that's also part of Trump
calculus here he's trying to stir the
pot wh o wh o has now to absolutely do a
little math and and for the time being
trying to skit by without potentially us
significant u.s. funding I really
actually don't think there's going to
come to this in the end that the US will
fully withdraw all funding of the w-h-o
because the wh o has critical function
not just for the US but for the rest of
the world and as soon as you say wh o
pandemics epidemics and what the wh
adieu does in its mission another word
for the u.s. critical comes to mind and
that's national security anything the wh
o does and doesn't do has an impact on
national security thoughts and and an
estimate here in the United States for
the United States chef Juan Simmons in
Washington DC
thank you